Hey youtubers it's Charlie what’s this,
this doesn’t look like it normally does,
I’m traveling right now but I still wanted
to do a few videos. this week in my Arrow
video I asked you to submit all your Season
3 and Flash questions. I picked 10 to answer
in this video with one bonus question. Thanks
for all your bonus video suggestions too.
If you're finding me for the first time I
do Marvel and DC videos every week. Be sure
to subscribe to get everything. I do Q&As
for the really big stuff or if you guys have
a special one you really want. So feel free
to request a special Q&A for anything.
So let's talk about some villains and Justice
League cameos. Careful for spoilers from season
2 if you haven't seen it yet. Here we go,
Question 1 - Kimberley asks Since suicide
squad will be more prominent on the show are
we to expect the appearance of Harley Quinn?
After her cameo this season Andrew Kriesberg
said that they never had any intention of
making her a real character on the show. It
was just meant to be an Easter egg for the
hardcore fans. But never say never. Stephen
Amell said this funny thing recently. Someone
asked him about Diggle becoming the John Stewart
Green Lantern and he invoked hollywoodntv
rules. He joked that in the world of TV, if
it looks good, it has a much better chance
of happening.
I think that Cassidy Alexa looked really good,
so there's a good chance we could see her
again. But I don't think it will be a big
huge role like the other Suicide Squad members.
Question 2 - Aramil Whisperwind asks how will
the timeline’s work with Oliver and Barry
going on each other’s shows without missing
their own episodes?
So you're asking how can Oliver be in Central
City doing Flash stuff at the same time he's
supposed to be on screen in Starling. What
they'd probably do in a situation like that
is write around the problem. So events are
separated by days. Like Oliver goes to Central
City on a Tuesday but is back in the New Arrowcave
by Wednesday.
And right now we have no idea what the crossovers
are going to look like except for what we
saw in the trailer. And that was Barry visiting
Oliver in The first episode of the Flash.
Because both shows are premiering the same
week. Arrow episode 1 will probably just pick
up that next day unless Grant Gustin comes
on Arrow. Which is totally possible.
It sounds confusing but it's really not. Whenever
episodes start again I'll try to address the
timelines of both shows throughout the season.
Question 3 - Sventu asks which other Justice
League members do you think we’ll see next
season?
I do think they'll do at least one new cameo
from a comic book character we haven't seen
yet. Not including the new villain. Probably
a b or c level person like a Justice Society
or someone inside the young justice universe.
There have been a lot of rumors that a live
action young justice show could happen in
the next couple of years. Not soon, but anyone
they bring on will probably be a character
that they can use on another show.
Question 4 - Shovel and Pick asks What role,
if any, do you think the Huntress will play
in season three?
I thinkmOliver and Amanda Waller will get
her out of prison to help out on a case. Andrew
Kriesberg already said that they're continuing
to develop the Birds of Prey dynamic on the
show. So think of Huntress coming back in
an episode that feels like a sequel to Birds
of Prey this season, only with Huntress helping
Oliver, Laurel and possibly Sarah if she gets
another cameo. It's possible that in the next
Birds of Prey episode Laurel could just occupy
Sarah's spot on the team. Even if she's not
Black Canary yet.
It would be like Huntress, Laurel and Felicity
teaming up. But anyone who hasn't gotten their
head chopped off is fair game for them to
bring back. Not just Huntress.
Question 5 - Gerry Do you think they’d ever
jump forward in time between seasons in the
future. Like fast forward.
No, just talking about story devices, I think
Arrow has made flashbacks their thing for
better or worse. If we do see Flash Forwards,
I think it will be via The Flash. Since Zoom
is a character that moves around in time a
lot. Plus Goeff Johns is writing on the show.
Remember how he wrote the Legion episode of
Smallville?
They could always do something similar on
the Flash. Where Barry Allen interacts with
the Legion of Superheroes. I wouldn't expect
something like that in season 1 though.
Question 6 - Dontforget asks Can you do a
video saying what you think the writers could
do to make season 3 better than season 2?
Ooh, that's gonna be tough. Right now they
have a few advantages that I think will help.
Team Arrow is at a low point. Even though
they defeated Slade, the collateral damage
was off the charts. So they have to go into
rebuilding mode. Oliver has to get his company
back, rebuild his fortune so they can buy
more cool toys.
They have to build out the new Arrowcave,
they have to integrate A newly super powered
Barry Allen into the team. I am counting Barry
as a member of Team Arrow this year, even
if he isn't around all the time. He is officially
part of the ever growing family.
So what a lot of professional sports teams
do in rebuilding years is focus on fundamentals.
So I think we'll see Oliver doing another
Rocky style training montage as he slowly
builds a stronger platform for the Team. Metaphorically
speaking.
The series takes a lot of it's story cues
from Christopher Nolan's Dark Knoght Trilogy,
but I don't think we're going to see a Dark
Knight Rises batman arc for him. That would
be a story they'd do if they ever ended the
series.
Question 7 - Ricardo asks do you think Solomon
Grundy could be the villain for season 3?
We could totally see Grundy again. We don't
really know what happened to him after last
season. He's just kind of floating around
somewhere. I don't think he'll be the main
villain.
Question 8 - Supergamelord asks What if they
build a smallville Clark/Lex relationship
between Barry/Eddie﻿?
I definitely think they're going to have a
'ship of sorts. But I think Thawne is going
to already know Barry is The Flash. There's
a couple things going on with the character.
I think they basically combined Eobard Thawne
and Hunter Zolomon. Eobard came from the future
and Zolomon worked with Barry at the police
station.
The only reason Eddie would have for killing
Barry's mother is because he knew Barry would
become the Flash someday. Which means he had
to come from the future. So the Clark/Lex
frenemies dynamic will be very different.
But they'll be working in the same building,
so I actually think it will be more interesting.
It will probably take Barry all season to
learn Eddie is Zoom but Eddie will known what's
going on from the start.
I'm mostly interested in home they weave the
time travel aspects into the story. Or maybe
they'll just side step it and change the comic
book version of what happened.
Question 9 - Navish asks Do you think that
Slade will be back.
Definitely, I think if he does come back it
will be Oliver visiting him in prison to get
information about the new villain. Like Clarice
Starling visiting Hannibal Lecter in Silence
of the Lambs.
In fact, if someone wants to draw Slade as
Hannibal Lecter, I'll put it in my Arrow video
next week. Just message me with the link or
post it in the comments.
Question 10 - Party Freak asks What about
Sin?
I hope we get to see another Bex cameo. Sarah
never told her about the League of Assassins
or the Mirakuru. So as far as we know she’s
still hanging around the glades. I’d really
like to see her get some more team ups with
Roy. That was one of my favorite episodes
this season.
And one last Bonus Question - Mahleks asks
what about Richard Dragon from the comics
being the villain. They’ve been using him
a lot lately?
Good suggestion, in the New 52 Comics, Dragon
leads the Longbow Hunters. Which were also
big classic Green Arrow villains. There was
even a really awesome trade paperback called
Longbow Hunters. I suggested it as a possible
storyline for the show to adapt in one of
my other season 3 predictions videos.
I think they’ll stick within the Green Arrow
Justice League universe, no matter who they
pick for the new villain.
So thank you so much everyone for submitting
questions. And thank you for your patience
this weekend. I’m traveling so I’m probably
only going to be able to do one video a day.
Be sure to go see Days of Future Past this
weekend. I’m posting my review tomorrow.
Right Now Click here for that. I’ll add
the annotation as soon as I post it. And click
here for my top 10 arrow season 3 teasers.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High fives!